سريراتشا هي واحدة من أشهر
الصلصات الحارة في العالم ، لكنها أكثر من
مجرد صلصة ، تبدأ قصة كيف
أصبحت هذه الصلصة الحارة المتواضعة في كل مكان
مع هذا الرجل الذي جاء إلى أمريكا
كلاجئ وصنع واحدة من
أنجح الصلصة الحارة.  الشركات في
العالم omakase gelato general Mayor Sam
الآن ما هو Galactica
plate حتى تخبر مدونتي أن مدونتي ستطاردنا
نحن البنيان ، هذه القصة الكبيرة الرائعة
تأتيك من دلتا عندما
نخرج إلى العالم نرى كل ما
نشاركه
[موسيقى]
ديفيد  تران هو صاحب أغذية Huy Fong ،
وهي العلامة التجارية الأكبر والأكثر شهرة من
sriracha الموجودة هناك اليوم ، إنه
يعامل موظفيه
لتناول غداء مفصل من فطائر King
Crab ونعم sriracha في مطعم ديم سوم الشهير
في أركاديا كاليفورنيا ، لكنه لم يكن
دائمًا  رئيس شركة كبيرة ديفيد
جاء إلى أمريكا منذ 40 عامًا بعد
فراره من وطنه فيتنام على
متن قارب ، وهو
ما لم يفرق السيد لا متأكدًا من
عدم وجود لحظة إسكانك بشكل
عام في العام وليس العام.  على العموم ، سأقفز إلى بلدي
القرف ما كنت المدينة المرهقة مثل جو
آسف
امرأة عمدة الوحدة ها مجرد
حواراتي منذ لحظة مولاتو الخاصة بك أنت
جورج سأخبر جيم نونكل جورجيا
دكتور.
لم تخترع Eve my David أنواعًا مختلفة من sriracha
على الصلصة التي تم العثور عليها في جميع أنحاء
جنوب شرق آسيا
في الواقع ، تم تسميتها على اسم بلدة في
تايلاند تحمل نفس الاسم ، الوصفة
بسيطة ، الزجاجة عبارة عن ثمانية
مكونات فقط ولكن صلصة David لها
مكون خاص لامرأة أكبر
tertia مهما كان عكرًا لإعطاء سيرة
ذاتية مختلفة إشارات يوهانسون كاملة
وأضواء أكبر في المدينة ،
رجل شاب [ __ ] ، المنطق في
إنجاز كبير لمتجر مياه ألفا
، كان لدى كيان الماوري الشاب نفس الطبقة
للاستمتاع بصقلية أكبر على الرغم من أنه لا يفعل ذلك
.  لدي أي تدريب رسمي في
الهندسة ، صمم ديفيد العديد من
العمليات في هذا المصنع حتى أنه
صمم الزجاجة الأيقونية أعرف ما الذي
ستحصل عليه بسعر رخيص سأفتح فتحة العدسة في
العالم كان شروتي لذا سيذهب
اشترى بينج واحد لديه إرشادات  من قبل
امرأة متأكدة أنني أتمنى
ألا يكون لديها IP قناة كبيرة
، تغني Yenta رسمت بعضًا
منها مليون خزان مياه في Pancho في
وضع الصرف الصحي في المنزل - افعل  ليس جودان د.  لي
قناة المياه الخارجية هم أشخاص من
ثقافات مختلفة لا يفهمون فقط
منتجات ديفيد التي يعشقونها ، دان هووا
تشو تاو كيف أفعل
ما سأقفز إليه كثيرًا إلى أن صاحب الخيال د
ما كثيرًا إلجين
ما صلابة نوعًا ما  وإلا فإن
لحم الخنزير الذي تم بيعه مرة أخرى نغمة
الإجهاض ستفعل دونا وتتفادى
الغاوسي لذا فإن ما قد
يمنحه الترديد لسيمزا المزيد من البيانات وروزين وجونا
[موسيقى]